hi everyone welcome to day 4 of digital
marketing week by simply learn on day
three we looked at social media
marketing today we are going to learn
two important skills in digital
marketing that is email and content
marketing email is one of the oldest
forms of digital communication and every
professional uses it email marketing is
still ranked as the most effective
marketing channel surpassing social
media seo and affiliate marketing it is
easy effective and inexpensive it also
lets you build brand awareness and
appeal and is perfect for personalized
targeted messaging content marketing on
the other hand helps answer your
audience questions and allows you to
build trust develop relationships
improve conversations educate your
audience and generate leads so in
today's live session we will cover what
is email marketing benefits of email
marketing and understand how to automate
emails and learn the types of email
marketing campaigns then we will
understand what is content marketing
look at the different content marketing
strategies and learn the important
content marketing interview questions
and answers so let's begin with what is
email marketing welcome everyone this is
rob sanders with simply learn and
welcome today we're going to talk about
email marketing tutorial so buckle up
and let's get started with email
marketing tutorial and so let's start
out asking the question why email
marketing so linda is the owner of an
e-commerce company and basically she
isn't able to take her leads the lead
she's collecting per day per month and
convert them into customers okay so
customers sign up but they don't buy her
product so she's left scratching her
head wondering what to do so how is she
going to solve the problem of converting
the lead she gets into paying customers
well look no further than email market
so you can boost your sales funnel with
the help of email marketing so email
marketing leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your tail i made is a very efficient way
to generate a return on my investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so linda is now
very interested we've peaked her
interest she wants
us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our product we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to re-market pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is a very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something and we
can come to the rescue in this case
we're going to come to the rescue with
email and we can go ahead and educate
them on what their need is and how we
can collaborate with them help them
educate them solve their problems with
our product okay so that's what email's
going to do we're going to communicate
with them via email and we're going to
bring awareness to the problem by
solving the problem that's what email is
good for okay good for generating
awareness for our brand for example we
can share a newsletter with our
customers so if we're running a
cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or
not sure what products to buy you know
an email can cover that okay the next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer smooths hydrates and
contains spf 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
talk about purchase the next step in the
life cycle well purchase well with
purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in our
inventory so what do we do we're going
to send an email we're going to send an
email to active customers okay we're
going to give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're gonna give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free
so you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers key is
the offer is exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer and then
what we want to do is advocacy last step
in that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that
they help they help the environment they
help the needy okay they care and so we
can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about
email marketing setup so email marketing
setup we have a series of steps that we
need to go through in order to get our
email set up to go ahead and send out to
our target audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create segments so if
you've taken some of my and listened to
some of my webinars in the past about
google analytics about google ads we
talk about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is taking a piece of the
whole so we don't want to email all
users on our list all customers maybe we
want to target a specific segment okay
so we want to be able to identify that
segment who is that segment is it
somebody who or a group of people or you
know a partial list of our customers who
purchase a specific product i would say
so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click send this is a very important step
test that email before we send and then
when we send the campaigns immediately
or we can schedule a time so
my advice here is always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out the
best time to send that email and then
once the email is sent whenever that is
you want to be able to analyze
performance and there are some key
metrics that you want to hone in on when
we talk about email marketing and some
of those are open rates click-through
rates okay response rate okay so we want
to be able to hone in on certain key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do create our
list add contacts to our list create our
campaign okay we want to select the list
choose a format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to mailchimp
so if i'm in mailchimp basically i'm
going to create a campaign okay
so
it's an email that i'm going to work
with and you can see with mailchimp i
have some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a b test i want
to do a regular email and i'm just going
to call it test and i'm going to click
begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose our audience okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay we can personalize the
two fields if we want okay so what do we
want to do we want to call people by
their first name their last name the
first and last name where we can
customize it just go with first name to
keep it a little bit personal okay then
we have the subject line here so it's
all about messaging right so whoever
we're targeting we want to be able to
add a message so we're just going to say
and and subject line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with them with them so that they can
open up that email okay so uh we'll just
say have any good day we can make it
better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email to figure out which one
has better open rates and then with
mailchimp we can go ahead and design the
content of our email so we're going to
click design email okay we can select a
template we have some save templates
already okay or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there i particularly like
mailchimp because of this very feature
they have a lot of good themes here um a
lot of different layouts that you can
use okay so you know we're going to
showcase that product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go we're going to
showcase our product we're going to add
that photo of our product here and we're
going to go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice call to
action we can put our logo up here for
branding again we can edit the content
here so based on that segmented list in
this example
for linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks who bought her
moisturizer before her face moisturizer
and she wants to retarget them she wants
to go ahead and say hey you guys have
bought my product before check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan out who
your audience is you want to plan out
your messaging and you want to go ahead
and set up the messaging based on that
audience so once you have the messaging
in place voila you're more or less ready
to go okay so
once you get the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign
okay and you can also add a social post
to your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about
who it is you want to target choose
those recipients
okay
customize it
and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's the checklist
to go off okay so remember identify
target audience and create segments then
you create that campaign and in our case
we did set an appropriate call to action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer key
thing here is before we send it out we
want to test that email once everything
looks good we're going to i would advise
schedule it but you can always send the
email when you're ready i would schedule
it at the appropriate time and day okay
so in this case you don't want to send
an email out on a friday afternoon okay
when people are getting ready for the
weekend you certainly don't want to send
an email out over the weekend because
you're not going to have many people
look and open it and you probably don't
want to send the email out on a monday
morning when most people are getting
into the office from a long weekend and
catching up on emails so
from my experience you know tuesday
wednesday depending on your time zone i
would always say you know late morning
early afternoon tends to be a good time
but that's why we have performance
that's why we can analyze performance we
want to be able to see what the open
rates are and the click-through rates
are so that we can make adjustments for
future emails so let's talk about some
of those metrics so when you do send
that email you know we're gonna look at
that open so open rate is the percentage
of the total number of recipients who
open an email so okay so if we basically
you know sent it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say you know we sent it to
102 people okay for simplicity's sake
two of those emails bounced okay so that
means that we've had a 100 net 100
emails that received the email and let's
just say 75 open the email okay we wrote
such a good subject line that they
opened it okay that's 75
that's a 75 open rate that's how you
measure open rate click through rate
okay so if they open it we hope that
they click on something and so for all
of those emails that were delivered okay
in this case a hundred how many actually
did click on our call to action so let's
just say
75 opened it out of the 100 that's a 75
open rate but of the hundred that
actually were delivered let's just say
we had
25 that actually clicked on the call to
action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who opens it but who
clicks on the call to action so that's
click-through rate for email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on a link of your email campaign
and actually completed the action so in
our example we're trying to get people
to click on the shopping call to action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails and of the 25 who actually
clicked we had 10 who actually took
action and purchase so 10 divided by 100
is 10
so you have open rate click-through rate
and response rate those are some key
metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line is
so important click their way that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action and then
the response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform mailchimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
april email coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14
open rate 1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better 19 open two and a half
percent on the click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually were sent how many opened it
and how many clicks so this is a
mailchimp makes it very easy for us to
measure you know open and click rates
and then we can measure by revenue as
well based on the campaign so
that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open rate and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to linda that it's
cost effective it's time saving real
time marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're gonna go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to when we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to
meet our customers needs at the right
time it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw i can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email so let's move
into a b testing so a b testing is key
to email marketing okay so in email
marketing gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
going to get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're gonna do that via a b testing i've
already mentioned it when i set up my
example campaign in mailchimp i stressed
and stressed and stressed that we need
to have two subject lines go out per
email okay so before i stress that again
let me just reiterate what a b testing
is and a b testing is a method to
analyze which of the two email campaign
strategies most effective in terms of
high open rates and click rates okay so
in this case an a b testing you can send
out two emails you can send out two
subject lines you can send out two call
to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example i talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so i wrote a
subject line i don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
i write a second subject line then i'll
be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
rate because i'm offering up two
different subject lines likewise for
email content so the subject line and
email content are the most important
elements so we want to be able to test
them if they're interesting intriguing
attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b test where linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a higher open rate okay so
in our example here linda sends version
a of the email to 50 of the recipients
with the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate
well version b which is sent to the
other 50
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate so
the only difference here is three and
three the number three spelled out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now be able
to measure the success of that a b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate numbers always
tend to work in subject lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
of the recipients okay 80 today but
ninety dollars tomorrow and version b to
the remaining fifty percent eighty
dollars today ninety dollars tomorrow
and the only really succinct difference
here is using the word but versus a
comma and she sent that email out and
that email went out and the data's
coming in and she's going to measure the
success of that a b test well version b
has the higher open rate you know we
want to be short
succinct and stay away from those
conjugations like but okay it tends to
have a negative connotation so the
shorter more direct email our subject
line 80 today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
high open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 with the subject
line uh-oh your prescription is expiring
version b
your prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder which one you think will perform
go ahead and put your comments right
below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a b test okay so she sent
the email out two different subject
lines fifty percent got one subject line
the other fifty percent got the other
subject line and it just so happens
version a uh-oh your prescription is
expiring there's a little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring seems to be a little bit more
you know command-ish hey your
prescription's expiring so we expect you
to purchase where you have a little uh
oh in front it's like hey you know i
think your prescription is expiring
maybe you should think about renewing it
okay i think that's how that's
interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates so in order
to keep improving those open rates you
need to continue and not continue should
always do subject line testing always
because one subject line is always going
to have a better open rate than the
other so always do a b testing when it
comes to subject lines and email content
for that matter okay so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test very various elements of the
email so you can always test the
sender's name the subject line the copy
the call to action the design the
imagery there's a lot of different
elements you can test with emails for
example
sender's name okay so you want to
personalize it as much as you can okay
you don't want to do a no reply you want
it to come from a human being in this
case sam okay at least that's what i
think let's see what the test states no
surprise version a has the higher open
rate if you customize these things and
personalize them then it goes a long way
sending an email from a no reply is not
a good
best practice let's talk about
the subject line again uh so we got
webinar increase your email open rates
so the webinar is dynamic on version a
okay so we're sending that out and
because it's dynamic that's going to you
know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy so learn some
easy ways to increase your email open
rates join us on may 10 2019 7 p.m for
an interactive discussion with our
experts well version b is more
personalized it's a same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case rachel so we can
measure the success of the a b test but
it's no surprise that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's going to increase click rates so we
can also test that call to action the
difference here is coloring save my seat
yellow versus save my c blue again go
ahead and play along here if you're
watching this go ahead and add a comment
and just see if you're right do you
think it's blue or you think it's yellow
on the call to action color does go a
long way in email marketing so let's
measure the success of this a b test and
it just so happens yellow is going to
perform better why does yellow perform
better than blue what's more positive
plus it it kind of resonates a little
bit stronger and easier okay it stands
out a little bit better it's not as
pastely and dull as this shade of blue
we're using so you can see here we're
testing every bit of the elements of the
email anything from the from to the
subject line to the message to the call
to action and so at the end of the day
you know you want to be able to
send out the best email that's going to
give you the best results so we're going
to send that out the entirety of the
email and we could see version a looks a
lot better and why does version a look a
lot better in this example because look
at the font size is a little bit bigger
version b font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them you know 48
points or 50 points and plus you know 14
versus 12 goes a long way we can
continue testing we can test imagery you
can see here we have a hand aligned with
the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version b has the other
type of hand aligned with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version b
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with
a no reply versus
somebody's name then we move to a
subject line then we move to
personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line gotta personalize the email to
rachel with larger font okay we got a
nice call to action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line your emails come a long way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sent out an
email last month with the subject line
about you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
percent people resonate with emojis
especially if they're positive emojis
okay so we want to personalize those
subject lines for better open rate okay
when i say personalize don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested uh
oh just putting uh oh in there made it
sound like we actually cared it was a
little bit personal it wasn't so
personal you weren't dressed in a
specific person but one little word goes
a long way in a subject line because
when people get emails and they read
emails and a lot of people are inundated
with emails the subject line is what
they're reading first and just by
personalizing it adding a number adding
an emoji just making it positive and
easy to read they're likely to open that
email so personalized email messages can
improve click through rate and open
rates as well so you want to personalize
your email as much as you can whether
that be from the from field to putting
that person's name in the salutation so
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
so don't come across as spammy come
across as you know who your audience is
and you're talking to them and then you
want to prefer title case subject lines
so title case subject lines for example
when i say title case game of thrones is
my favorite show every initial letter in
that title is capitalized okay you can
go with the sentence case game of
thrones is my favorite show it doesn't
stand out as much of course if you go
with lowercase it definitely doesn't
stand out it looks illiterate and
somebody's probably not going to open it
so you always go with that title case
the every initial letter gets
capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within 17 17 and
24 characters so according to campaign
monitor the ideal length of a subject
line is up to 24 characters and they're
more likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short make it impactful
make it personalized like i mentioned
before if you get too long then it may
get cut off and it may not have the same
impact as something shorter so that's
why we always recommend keeping it up to
about 24 characters okay if you go over
by a couple characters not the end of
the world but try and stay within that
range develop a sense of urgency okay so
when we say sense of urgency we mean
sense of urgency meaning if that coupon
is going to expire
you want to let people know it's going
to expire that day or the next day or
within a few days okay so you can use
things like hurry up or limit offer or
limited stock or offer expires on okay
so add a bit of sense of urgency i mean
sky is not falling here but if that
coupon's expiring at the end of the week
you probably want to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up so let's talk about optimizing
your email content so we focused a lot
on subject lines let's talk about the
email content itself so some ways to
optimize email content are we want to
send the content that is relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation we want to use
bullet points to make the content
readable we want to follow logical
structure we want to use compelling
imagery and prefer design emails with
responsive designs and what we mean by
responsive design is hey most people are
going to be checking that email on their
mobile phone okay so
make sure when you design the email it's
also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes go
ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on testing your
email before you actually send it and
when you actually send an email test
email don't send it to yourself send it
to colleagues you know send it to
another group a fresh set of eyes a
fresh set of eyes like it's going to be
able to pick out that misspelled word
that you overlooked so i can't stress
the sending of the test email because
it's going to be able to
you know in a way ensure that you're
doing everything on this list in
addition to grammatical mistakes you
know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work may be
looking at that email on their mobile
phone and if it doesn't look good to
them they're gonna let you know some
other ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it question is hey do i use first name
do i use first and last name well guess
what you can test that but you want to
personalize it okay you want to choose
the right fonts and colors for your
email so
when we were going through some examples
on testing you know i always tend to go
a little bit larger on the font but you
can play around with it i don't think
you should probably use white lettering
on a black background that just is not
very good or best practice but go ahead
and try it if you want okay you can
always play around and test these but
you want to choose something that's
really going to resonate with the
recipient of the email okay you want to
build a rapport with customers by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about you know
sharing with them some of the
non-profits that we work with as a
company okay if we have a you know
cosmetics company and we have different
products like moisturizers and facial
creams we may
want to state that hey we don't use any
animals in the testing of these products
you know we're pro animal we're not you
know we're not going to use animals in
the testing of our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to go
ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights okay
and use recipient names and you always
want to personalize it then add a clear
call to action at the end you always
want to have that call to action
regardless of what the email is hey
could be just a simple read more or hey
donate it doesn't have to always be so
hardcore in terms of hey purchase our
product that could be a turn off
especially if you're sending emails out
once a week to your customer base
they're constantly hammering them with
buy now buy now by now they're going to
get turned off so you want to mix up the
call to actions and that goes back to
the very first step and what kind of
email are you going to send out and who
are you going to send it to so you have
to align those two with somebody who
doesn't even know who your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now you're probably going to say
hey check us out we have some cool stuff
for you okay let's talk about automating
emails email automation so triggered
emails are sent to customers based on an
event date or user behavior okay so when
we say an event could be a special
occasion like mother's day okay could be
a date like a birthday or anniversary or
specific day of the week could also be
based on user behavior you know a good
example of user behavior are those who
abandon the car you can trigger an email
in fact mailchimp has remarketing
functionality so with mailchimp hey if
somebody abandons our car we can have an
email triggered and we could send an
email a nice email that says hey we
noticed you didn't finish purchasing our
product and i'm not sure what happened
but hey here's another 10 percent off or
you can always just make product
recommendations as well but you want to
react to user behavior and use emails to
your advantage for that so you want to
take be cognizant of different occasions
you want to be cognizant of special
events holidays etc and user behavior so
these types of emails can be automated
because you know when they might happen
or that they are probably going to
happen so auto responder emails are sent
at frequent intervals based on the
behavior of subscribers so for example
if somebody purchases something then
you're going to get an email that
probably says hey thank you for your
purchase another email that says hey
your products on its way and then
another email that says hey your package
your product has been delivered so
that's an example of an automated email
that goes out if somebody purchases your
product you probably want to thank them
for that then you probably want to let
them know that hey it's on its way here
you could track it and then again you
want to confirm that it's been delivered
but thank them again so that's an
example of an automated email that goes
out okay let's talk about types of email
campaigns so we have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and informed
about product updates so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a product they
buy it could be a product they subscribe
to like software okay you always want to
be able to send out that newsletter to
let them know what's going on with your
product are there upcoming product
updates ahead is it one that just
happened is there a webinar that
discusses the new product update so
that's what the newsletter is going to
do inform the end user about the update
so how to optimize okay so you stack
your email content create a compelling
header
share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc with
those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so that's how you
handle a newsletter you should always
create a compelling header but if you're
going to send a newsletter make sure you
support it with some good information
like a video that they can go watch or
an article that will follow up on what
you put in the email or promoting that
webinar that's going to talk about that
product update so example here is a
newsletter that gets sent out and here
you can see it talks about business
process it's got some nice imagery in
there okay call to action it's got a
little bit of everything in this email
template okay and that's when we talk
about stack your email content that's
what you talk about stacking you can see
at the top it's got work with the
industry best subscribe now okay they
validate that with 25 years of top notch
service then they talk about hiring the
best talent and you got the next bit of
content below that so that's stacked
email content okay that's going to be
supported by compelling header and then
they're going to share a variety of
different content in there like there
could be clicks in there to video videos
and articles moving on from newsletters
to promotional emails so we want to be
able to drive revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on if it's personalized then you
can say hey
so and so we know you're a mother here
take 20 off i mean that kind of
personalized email with an offer goes a
long way
here you an example from toms limited
time extra 20 off all styles they
include the code in there okay again you
can see the the sensitivity and the
sense of urgency with the limited time
another email campaign type and
personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart so abandon card emails i
like working with the banner card emails
because you know we want people to
purchase and as much as you try on your
email marketing campaign to drive
traffic to the website and as hard as
the website works to get people to
convert through the shopping cart it's
never gonna be a hundred percent and so
abandoned cart emails give us that extra
incentive to get that person back to the
shopping cart to purchase okay so these
emails are shared with customers who
have added product to their cart but
didn't finish through the checkout
process in other words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person who just is almost there but
not quite ready to finish the purchase
so what are we going to do we're going
to send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're going to use
a simple abandoned cart email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so as customized as
it can be it could be even the product
image of what they've abandoned and
that's the best practice so
if it's that facial moisturizer that
linda's trying to promote and she can't
quite get enough people to finish
purchasing the product they're they're
banning the cart well she can certainly
send out the abandoned cart email okay
so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly it's a gentle reminder okay so
come across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so and so 20 off on
your car valid until so and so offer on
your favorite product so the first email
that went out and the series of emails
hey you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you complete
the product purchase email too is just
that gentle reminder hey we're selling
out quickly you might want to purchase
that product and the email three is to
really help them along by saying hey
here's 20 off valid until so and so so
just a small series of emails that go
out try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart okay let's talk about
re-engagement campaign so in a
re-engagement campaign it's a series of
emails sent to inactive email
subscribers so what it does is it boosts
engagement and helps to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio inbox placement
ratio so we want to be able to make sure
that we're getting people back on our
subscriber list so how are we going to
optimize for something like this this is
now these are difficult type of email
campaigns we're trying to re-engage with
people who are inactive so we want
gamification to re-engage subscribers or
we want to prefer subject lines like hey
we've been missing you or did we do
something wrong okay we can run a poll
or competition to re-engage with our
subscribers so for example hey we'd hate
to miss your birthday go ahead and
update your account this is a starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so it's that you know message of missing
you you can always soften or sweeten the
deal with an offer as well so that
brings us to how to engage with new
subscribers so we just talked about
re-engaging with inactive we want to
talk about engaging with new subscribers
so how to engage with new subscribers
well thank your subscribers for joining
okay create clear and compelling subject
lines that is a must regardless of what
type of email you send out you always
want to send out that compelling subject
line okay noticed the good examples
within 17 to 24 characters know the
ideal time to message okay again sending
it on the weekends not gonna work okay
sending it out during the weekday you
know in the morning mid-morning you know
sometimes in the afternoon works really
depends on who your audience is but
weekends probably aren't going to work
they avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally you know let them
know that the email's coming from a real
person okay because if it doesn't come
from a person most people aren't going
to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you know straight with people
who are new they don't know your brand
they don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again
personalization always personalize if
it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link i can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to
unsubscribe even if it was a good email
i still look for that because maybe
they're good company but they're
spamming me they're sending me too many
emails so maybe i want to unsubscribe or
change my subscription so you always
want to include that unsubscribed link
in fact in the united states it's
actually law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there i use
mailchimp i've used a few in the past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them again
mailchimp marketo marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
hubspot convert kit send in blue
aweber i mean these are just some of the
many that are out there okay so let's
show a demo again of an email marketing
campaign so let's show an example of a
newsletter that
one of my clients had sent out and so
this is paul ekman group paul ekman dr
ekman inspired the tv show lied to me so
well known in the industry of micro
expressions he's the aforementioned
expert in microexpressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns and he
sends out a monthly newsletter so this
is a newsletter was sent out in november
2018. and if we look at it you can see
here okay it's stacked content nice
imagery okay respectful disagreements
how to deal with disagreements this
holiday season so really relevant
personalized because and timely because
it was set in november during the
holiday season so
got some nice imagery there okay we got
content in here and then right below
that on the stack content what do we
have final hour 24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in to
the email then here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an example of a
micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use microexpressions
to your advantage so call to action here
then we have some more information here
with the learn more so a newsletter that
went out basically
a blog post built into the email with
some nice content reminding folks hey
they have 24 hours got some other useful
information in the email so this email
went out very timely 98 000 okay see
subject line here controversy respectful
disagreements and thanksgiving okay
could the subject line be a little bit
shorter yes possibly but if we look at
the open rate 15
16 open rate okay industry average
in education and training is 18 okay so
they're close to the industry average on
the click rate you know 1.6 percent on
the click rate industry average 2.1 so
we can see what the top links were
clicked okay so they have a lot of links
and and mailchimp will help you measure
what links were clicked the most who
subscribed what subscriber with the most
opens we can see opens by country but
that's an example of a newsletter for
this particular company okay stacked
content okay sense of urgency okay you
can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email for the time of year okay so let's
go over the checklist again for email
marketing so good reminders on the
checklist this is a checklist you want
to make sure
all boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rates direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure not only is it personalized
but the name aligns with the email
address okay you should always
personalize always personalize the
subject line and the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello to sally pete rob
michael etc always include an
unsubscribe link in emails and give
people the option to unsubscribe okay
you can always re-engage them another
way or later on but you don't want to
irk any one of your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar there's lots of
different elements we can test from
subject line to content to font to call
to action to imagery to subject line etc
there's no shortage of elements in an
email you can test you want to use
welcome emails to build good customer
relationships so when somebody signs up
for a newsletter send out a welcome news
email to them hey welcome thank you for
signing up you should always segment
your list based on user behavior so you
have a group of people who purchase
product a customize your email for
product a but you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is so you can talk to your
audience and you can always ask your
subscribers to update their preferences
as well because you want to make sure
you're sending out emails to the right
person right address okay this is a
short checklist now we can expand upon
this but these are some of the most of
the key items when it comes to email
marketing some other items on the
checklist include features such as
countdown timers and live polls okay
make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week once a
week is probably as much as you want to
go depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something then you probably
want to send an email thanking them for
the purchase another one letting another
product has been shipped and another one
with thank you the product has been
received reward those subscribers send
out exclusive offers okay make sure your
emails are optimized for mobile that
means send out test emails and check it
on different devices
create a schedule okay you can automate
these emails so create a schedule that
makes the most sense have a footer and
header in the email and in that footer
and header is going to be some
information okay just like i showed you
with the micro expressions there was a
footer and header avoid spam filters
okay how do you avoid spam filters well
apply best practices and don't have
spammy subject lines have an actual name
associated with the reply to email and
split up your list as well when you send
out one email to 150 000 people it could
probably get caught up in some spam so
segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging can be
specific to the audience that's going to
help avoid spam and then of course you
always want to measure and analyze
results so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms have the results
built in especially open rates and click
rates we're going to talk about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp as your email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp so the first thing you need to
do is sign up for an account with
mailchimp and that's simply just
providing an email address an id and a
password and i recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with the free plan first and let's
take a look at what the feature plan
features are for mailchimp so i'm
recommending the free plan but when you
actually sign up you have the option to
actually pay for a plan so you have the
essential the standard the premium or
the free and so i recommend you go with
the free version first it's like buying
a car you want to test drive it out see
if you like it see if you like the
features and benefits and you can see
here that with the free plan you get a
lot of features and benefits so you get
all the basics for businesses that are
just getting started so if you're just
getting started with email marketing i
would recommend the free plan here
because you have a 2 000 contact maximum
so that means you can send out an email
to your 2000 recipients free of charge
so not a bad deal for businesses who are
starting out i mean if you are prepared
you've used mailchimp before then go
ahead and sign up for one of the paid
versions
each version has a different set of
standards a different set of features
and benefits from the essential all the
way up to the premium where you're gonna
get you know advanced features um and
more customization but that's
dollars a month so if you're not
prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do set up your
account you're just gonna again provide
a id email address and password you're
going to go through a couple of steps
and one of these steps that i would
recommend you do right away is connect
to your facebook and twitter accounts so
if you already have a facebook and
twitter account very simple all you're
doing is authorizing mailchimp to
connect the account and the reason for
that is when you actually connect your
twitter facebook account you'll be able
to then you know share content on those
platforms and mailchimp will do that for
you automatically okay so here you're
just asking it to
more or less interact with the platform
social platform and i recommended doing
that as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do if you're
already logged into your twitter
facebook account all you need to do is
click on the plus button as you go
through the setup wizard and authorize
mailchimp to access your twitter or
facebook account here you can see what
mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to read tweets
from your timeline post tweets for you
on your behalf if you want them to if
you want them to you're gonna allow
mailchimp to see create and manage your
advertising data including the campaigns
and audiences and the reason for this is
you may you know want to integrate your
email marketing efforts with your social
media efforts and the great thing about
mailchimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from facebook and twitter and
integrate them with mailchimp you'll be
able to so having these two platforms in
the case of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but i recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template
just by default you could pick one just
to get the account going but you can
always go back and add or change out the
template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i arbitrarily just chose a template
i can go back and choose some of the
templates that are available to me now
again you can create your own template
if you want to okay so you just click
create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a you know template that you can
pretty much change and customize so if
you're thinking about sending out an
email with an announcement then that's
the type of template you want to choose
and so here now you can see we have a
logo we can change the announcement here
we can add photos etc so if i want to
add my logo i'm just going to go up to
this top portion here click the little
pencil icon that allows me to edit here
you can see it's the default logo i
don't really have a logo so i can say
replace it i can also link to it and
here you can see
in the content studio of mailchimp i
don't have any images to choose from so
i'm going to go ahead and upload one and
i'm going to go ahead and upload my logo
that i've had on my desktop okay so it's
going to upload and now i can select
that and insert it so now i have my logo
as part of my template here and
you can also see you can add some
styling here to this hot header part so
i can add a nice border around that okay
so i can align its center i can go edge
to edge okay so i can customize the
image in this particular template here
so i'm just going to click save and
close now i'm ready to move on to the
next part which is just click on edit i
want to make an announcement okay share
your big news okay we're
having a launch party okay so here you
can see again just in this template this
quote-unquote announcement template i'm
able to just make changes to each
section now i'm in the section of the
announcement part where i can now
customize the text and you can see i can
you know bold it you know i can choose a
different font go ariel i can choose the
size you can make it smaller larger
pretty easy to use i could again style
it with different color and so i can
make multiple columns here if i want to
so there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well so let's go ahead
and just do one more thing here let's
maybe call it or something i mean you
can see i can add a link let's go ahead
and make it blue that's the background
so i want to change the background so
i'm just going to click ctrl z i'll
change the color of the font itself
there you go very simple and easy to use
now i can add photos here if i want to
so let's go ahead and edit this bottom
part here so i'm going to click again
the edit icon okay so here you can see i
have three images in the template i'm
going to go ahead and add to that so
here i can go ahead and upload some
files so i have some files waiting for
me on my desktop i'm just going to go
ahead and add them and upload them to
the content studio and
now that i've uploaded them i can select
one of them to insert okay now i'm going
to go here insert the second one and now
i'm going to grab the third one and
insert that in its place here you can
see now i can go ahead and you know
style each one of these if i want to
okay i can add a border again okay i can
go ahead and do rounded corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical i can do
this so i have a lot of flexibility
and
what i add to these particular you know
templates okay this is again just the
announcement template and so now i'm
going to click save and close
and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i could play
around with the design and header and
once i'm done really if i'm happy with
my email i can just close it out and i'm
done so what i could do now is when
you're done with this template you can
just preview and test it so i could send
a test email or enter preview mode so if
i enter preview mode this is what the
template i chose is going to look like
if i happen to send it out okay this is
what it looks like on desktop this is
what it looks like a mobile and if i go
inbox preview i'll need to upgrade my
account because i'm on the free version
so but i can certainly see what it looks
like on mobile on desktop so i'm just
going to click out of that and this is a
template and so i can go back and edit
this anytime i want so when i'm done i'm
just going to go ahead and click the
mailchimp
icon in the upper left it's going to ask
me to name my template so i'm going to
name this the announcement template i'm
going to click save and now it's in my
templates so i'm free to use this
template anytime i'm ready to send an
email okay and again i can you saw how
easy it was to make a change in the
template itself so when i'm ready to use
the template i can just go ahead and
grab it okay and again i can go ahead
and style it and design it any way i
want so you have different sections of
the page that you can style and here you
got you know mobile style designs if you
wanted to now if you wanted to in the
template if i want to like duplicate the
whole blog i can duplicate that whole
block and you can see it just copied it
or i can just get rid of it it's a very
easy to use
wysiwyg if you will or interface it
allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again i'm
working with a template here so anytime
i'm ready to use that template for an
email i can go in and start using it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
gonna find my template here i can always
edit it i can always share it i can
always preview it i can replicate it and
that's the important thing so if i
replicate it i'm basically creating a
copy of it okay so i just created a copy
so now if i wanted to create a or change
the copy of it i can do that so if i
don't like this whole block i can just
delete it and now that i'm done i can
rename this i'm just going to say
announcement template v2 so now it's
been renamed and now i have two
templates just simply by choosing one
and replicating it so again if i go back
to templates here here i go i have my
two templates and i can store these in a
folder so i'm gonna add a folder i'm
gonna call it announcements and i'm
gonna add the folder and that's it so
now i can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so i'm
going to take these two templates here
move them to my announcements folder and
there you go they're in the
announcements folder so if you're going
to create multiple templates then i
would recommend you go ahead and
organize it create folders you know and
set up as many folders as you want and
need because you're going to probably
have different templates for different
occasions depends on what type of email
you're sending out so i just chose
arbitrarily an announcement type email
so now if i go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again i just chose
make an announcement you can tell a
story follow-up educate
you've got all sorts of different
templates that you could choose all
sorts and here you got some themes so
you can even go with a theme if you
wanted to so for example if you're
selling products let's just say you have
a boutique store let's just choose this
boutique template if i choose this here
is my themed template and so now
just like the other template i was
working in i can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top i got the
middle section you know i got all these
different sections that i can now go
ahead and edit so it's just about really
it's about choosing the theme template
that works best for you and feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you so
here you can add in certain things like
you know social share so if i just drag
and drop i can add in a social share
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do in
terms of the design in terms of the
content so again if you go back and i'm
going to cancel and not save this temp
well let's save it we'll call it
boutique we may use it again in the
future so i'm going to go ahead and
click save
and now it's a template it's going to be
located in templates and again if you
always want to access templates just go
to templates you'll see the templates
that you already have created and added
so you can edit them always just by
clicking the edit button now that's
again if you want to create a new
template just create click on the create
new template call to action again you
got themes you've got layouts or you can
even create your own from scratch you
can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch and html so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation i like some of
the layouts that mailchimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one again you're in
full control of how to
design and message it so you're in full
control of that so if you just want it
again tell a story i'm going to select
this template here okay now i'm on the
free version so keep in mind with the
free version i don't have access to all
the templates so here i get an upgrade
to use this one but for example if i
don't see the message upgrade to use
then i'm free to grab it so you can see
the one column i'm free to use so i'm
just going to select that and now i have
this template available to me so again
i'm free to edit this one as i see fit i
mean i can go ahead and again drop in
any one of these elements that are
available to me here i'm going to drop
in my social block okay so here you can
see i can now customize my social block
if i want to add in another platform i
can do that social media platform click
save and close so you can see they're
very customizable all of these themes
and layouts are very customizable and
again when you're done it's just a
matter of you can preview it or test it
you can enter preview mode or you can
send yourself a test email okay if you
send yourself a test email you can
actually see how it looks when it comes
in so let's go ahead and do that here so
i'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email has been sent so
let's go check our inbox so here is the
email that
i just created from the theme you can
see here all i did simply when i edited
i just dropped in my social block in
here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about mailchimp
is they have an option that
you can view the email in a browser if
you can't or you don't want to look at
it in your in this case i'm looking at
gmail so you can always or recipients
can always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific now when it comes to
completing your profile on mailchimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into mailchimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see i already have one contact
that contacts me because i added my
email address on that test email so
mailchimp is smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're going to add them
so here we can see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if i click on
import here i'm going to be asked to
import either from a csv or copy and
paste or i can just go ahead and
integrate it so if i choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context i have there and so
it's up to you how you import your
contacts now the whole point of contacts
is you want to probably or really not
probably it's a best practice to
actually create different lists so that
you can use different audience lists
with different emails and so here you
can see i have one email address i can
again import contacts or i can add them
individually so i can add subscribers
here okay that's another option that's
the slower option my recommendation be
import them but when you import make
sure you you're importing lists that
have some commonality so you can manage
those lists so if you have one list that
are say
you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way i would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
gonna get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp that allows you to
you know build out your audience just by
using one of their forms so again we
have a subscriber pop-up you've probably
seen some of these on some of the
websites you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example all they need to do is enter
in their email address and click
subscribe okay that's the the pop-up
version now again you have the
opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here or an embedded
form okay where you can integrate the
form okay so if i click form
integrations here i can use wufoo or
squarespace i can integrate with them if
i go back to signup forms if i choose
form builder here i have a signup form
and then i can customize that form with
different boxes okay or fields okay so
whatever field i want somebody to add
information to i can have that in there
and then this form could be you know on
your website so that's a great feature
about mailchimp is it helps you build an
audience so i can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form is going to be added to
my subscriber list that i can use for
future emails to take that a step
further i can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if i click on audience i can
go ahead at the bottom right here i have
an option to create a landing page so if
i click on that just like everything
else in mailchimp it's fairly easy to
use i'm just going to name it test click
begin here i can choose my audience
again i can what audience do i want to
add these emails to i click begin and
i'm going to accept and here now i have
all these different templates that i can
use as a lanny page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just going to choose
one you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so i can customize it just
like i do with my email template i can
add my logo okay i can start adding
different fields here like an image i
can drop an image here okay i can go
ahead and
you know drop in my social shares okay i
can drop in a box text box okay and then
i can start customizing it with some
text some imagery you know some other
information again this is a landing page
that i can then add to my website and so
anytime somebody goes to the landing
page and fills out their email address
and hits subscribe it's going to be
added to that audience list and then i
can turn around and send an email using
one of mailchimp's templates to that
audience so mailchimp really does a
great job of allowing you to grow your
list within your own website via a
landing page a form submission or or
forum or pop-up so there are lots of
different options available to us so i'm
going to click save and close here and
now this landing page is available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these emails go to i
can add a page title and again i can
edit the design so i can really make
this an integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website i can add a specific
url and i can add a nice page title to
it so mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on facebook or
google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in mailchimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if i click on
content studio here here you can see the
files i've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you can certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giffy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have instagram so what
you can do is you can integrate you know
any one of your instagram accounts if
you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your mailchimp account and when you
do that it's gonna pull in all the
images that you've had on instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending down emails you're going to have
the option to look at reporting to see
how those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see how we fared on some of our
emails okay so for example if i send out
an email here in april and this is april
2019 i could see how many total
subscribers i've had now along with the
number of subscribers you have you have
what we call open rate and click-through
rate now we explain a lot of the
reporting and the specific email metrics
and another recording that we did
last week so if you're interested in
learning more about some of the metrics
then check out the video that we have on
youtube email marketing tutorial uh we
recorded this last week go into details
about all the different metrics you
uh can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in mailchimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with mailchimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we could see in this particular
email last year in april you know we've
had 14 14 1.1 percent to be exact and
that is 13
377 divided by 97 469 so that's how many
people open the email so thirteen
thousand out of ninety seven is about
fourteen percent now when somebody opens
it we hope they're going to click on it
and so here we got a one point four
percent click rate again that's the
total number of clicks based on the
total number of subscribers or people
that were sent the email and so
mailchimp just gives you a nice overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular
audience list and then the open rating
click rate so we can really dive in here
and we can actually see how that
particular email performs so if we just
pick one email here we can just click
view report we have other options here
we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email looked like we could select that
so we just want to view the report so
we're going to click view report and now
we can get into some nice detailed
information about the actual report
itself so again here you can see total
number of recipients and this came from
the audience list called newsletter okay
was delivered last year september 26
2018 again i have the option to view it
download it print it or share it so
let's take a look and view the email to
see what it looked like okay so this is
what the email look like we have our own
template here and here you can see it
takes into account some of the best
practices involved with email marketing
you know we have some nice content
imagery some call to action here some
other links okay we have our social
icons okay so that's what the email
looked like okay so we'll go back and
we're going to click view report now we
want to view the report again here's
what it look here's when it was sent
okay the open rate for this was 21
click-through rate was 4
so for us the list average this list
here newsletter the average was for the
open rate 16.8 percent so we're above
the average on this email for the
click-through rate the list average is
2.7 so we're above the average so we've
done a good job on this email at least
generating more opens more clicks and
mailchimp even takes that a step further
they'll even show you what the industry
average is for your particular industry
and in this case we're education and
training so we did better than the
industry average for both the open rate
and for the click-through rate so we
could see some other specifics we could
see the raw numbers of opens clicks how
many people bounced meaning the email
address wasn't valid anymore and so
mailchimp does a good job of any email
that actually bounces it'll be scrubbed
and removed from your list and then here
you can see 347 unsubscribe so the the
thing about you know mailchimp is we
want to be careful we don't have too
many unsubscribes and also people
abusing or reporting abuse meaning you
don't want to send out an email multiple
multiple times a week where it gets the
point where it's spammy and so you want
to avoid a high number of unsubscribes
and a high number of abuse reports and
so here you can see
most emails are open within a 24 hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within 24
hour period okay so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's going to
tail off from there great thing is
mailchimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so i
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here
whether you use mailchimp or you use any
other platform whether that be vertical
response or any other type of email
marketing platform you want to use utm
tracking with your links so that google
analytics can pick up the actual
campaign so here you can see we have utm
tracking appended to our links and let
me just go in to detail on that for just
a minute so mailchimp again gives us
nice data on open and click-through
rates but when we send out an email and
people actually do click on one of these
links they're going to go to our website
and from there google analytics is going
to take over on the tracking so this is
as far as mailchimp goes so we want to
be able to bridge the gap between
mailchimp reporting and google analytics
meaning when they came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking which is simply
appending the original url with some
tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do when you set up a
mailchimp campaign is just go to url
builder in google then you're going to
click on campaign url builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign so for example if we go back
here this was the original url so if i
just copy this original url here and
paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm going to
put mailchimp with my medium i'm going
to put email so mailchimp is the source
of where the traffic came from the
medium the means in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
the campaign name we're just gonna put
maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the url and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here i can see mailchimp
email summer promo and then for the
content i can use that to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original url
with a new url appended with utm
tracking so if i copy that i can simply
just paste that in my browser just to
see if it works and here you can see it
works the page loaded the original url
with utm tracking and so that's exactly
what you want to do because when you're
looking at your reports in mailchimp
it's going to show me the top links that
were clicked now if i go into analytics
i want to be able to see how that
campaign or how that link actually
performed so let's take a look at that
real quick so if i go to my google
analytics account and i go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am i looking for well if i click on
source and medium source and medium are
to the parameters for utm tracking i'm
going to look for mailchimp so here i
could see
my original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp and then the medium's email
so if i go back here i can see for
example any one of these mailchimp
emails that went out and then i can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the balance rate was meaning
if they arrived on the site did they
leave after arriving or did they
actually go to another page and then i
could see other engagement data like how
many pages they looked at did they how
much time did they spend more
importantly did they convert so that's
the whole idea behind using utm tracking
because with utm tracking you can can
bridge the gap from open rate
click-through rate to behavior on the
website all the way through to the
conversion and that's what we want to
measure we want to measure did somebody
go from the email open it click on one
of the links go to the website engage on
the website and convert and so that's
the whole idea behind utm tracking
because mailchimp and any other email
marketing platform is only going to give
you at most your open rates and your
click-through rates okay so here we
could see the top links clicked i see 4
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site and now i need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here i can see what subscribers had
the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your twitter
account or your facebook account you'll
be able to
integrate that email in with your
twitter and then from there i'll be able
to see you know tweets or or how many
likes for example and to top it off i
can see how many people from around the
world clicked on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links uh you can look
at social so if i click on the social
tab here if i integrated my social i can
look at social reporting
likewise for e-commerce and notice
analytics 360 i can integrate google
analytics in with mailchimp if i want to
so i have all sorts of options on my
reporting so that's it for mailchimp i
mean it's fairly easy to navigate you
have all the campaigns that you've sent
out so if you just click on campaigns
i'll be able to see all the campaigns
i've set up and all the campaigns that
have been sent and obviously the ones
that have been sent i can start looking
at reports i can pick and choose
templates okay i can pick and choose my
audience and manage my audience okay i
can see what the growth is from my
audience again i have different options
to grow my audience okay i can certainly
add form submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are going to be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to giffies to instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in mailchimp we're going to cover
the email marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's going to work so if
you have any questions
to these questions or answers feel free
to just comment right below this video
and we'll get back to you as soon as
possible we're going to go through a
series of questions and i'm going to
answer those questions for you so email
marketing's traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while and you're gonna be asked some
questions that are gonna encompass a lot
of things related to the delivery of
emails uh we all check emails on a daily
basis we all receive them sometimes we
receive emails unsolicited sometimes we
sign up to receive emails sometimes we
receive emails from friends sometimes we
receive emails where we're working or
previously worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're going to get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering an actual mail to a post
office so it actually reached the post
office but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so not
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so next question here
what would you do to improve the
click-through rate of your email so
click-through rate is simply how many
people have seen your email and how many
people actually clicked on a link in the
email so if a hundred people saw your
email but only one person clicked then
it would be a one percent click-through
rate so we want to be able to make sure
we have a high click-through rate so
remember emails are going to people who
likely signed up to receive your email
and even if they are expecting an email
or they're not expecting an email you
still want to follow some of these best
practices here one is to create a
compelling subject line so you want to
make the subject line
something that people are going to
notice take note of or take an interest
in and say hey what's this all about
that's pretty interesting and open the
email so use preview text effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links so
put some strong call to action in there
and that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you can send
out the same email twice except one
segment's gonna say get one version of
the email the other segment is gonna get
another version of email and what are
the different versions maybe the subject
line so the subject line is different on
version a versus version b or maybe the
call to action is different so you
always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see which
segment or which version got the most
clicks okay so next question here is how
to inform your customers about company
news and establish a relationship with
your target audience okay so again how
do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company and how
are you going to establish a
relationship with that audience who's
receiving that email well newsletters
are always the best answer here so
somebody signs up for your email let's
just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software maybe hey we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more
update upgrade whatever so newsletters
the way to go so again some basic tips
here you want to create your newsletter
with 90 educational and 10 percent
promotional so remember you're sending
out a newsletter to people who likely
signed up so you're educating them about
your products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so make sure you design your
emails appropriately okay so if you know
you're sending let's just say baby
products to mothers or expected mothers
in fact this is a real life example
because i used to work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light
blues you know it wasn't black or dark
red or anything that's going to be you
know heavy we knew who our audience was
and we designed the template accordingly
and of course using compelling images so
for selling baby products you're gonna
put baby product images in there i mean
it's common sense but you'd be surprised
you gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
we already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who balanced it
whether it's a soft bounce or hard
bounce okay you're not going to count
those people so
if you have let's just say
20 people open the email and you sent it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click-through rate again
pop quiz it's just how many people
actually clicked on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of emails you've sent out a
response rate okay so response rate is
the percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on the link of your email
campaign and actually completed an
action so what is that action well it
could be downloading something watching
something purchasing something so that's
the response rate similar to conversion
rate if you're working in a digital
marketing channel and you're driving
traffic to the site you want that
traffic to do something well it's no
different in email marketing we want
people to take action we're just going
to divide that by the number of emails
delivered and that gives you your
response rate so let's just say you did
send in 100 emails you did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on a purchase well you'd
have a one percent response rate and
then a forward rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how to recapture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or a competition and re-engage their
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look i haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend say design always matters
especially knowing that you're talking
to customers who haven't been active
okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that customer's inactivity so you want
to try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so what are the
different ways to segment buyer personas
so again when we talk about segmentation
we're talking about taking a smaller
piece the entire pie so what's one way
to break up that pie if you will by
geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and blizzards as our theme
we're gonna use probably a little bit of
sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging then you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got clicked the rate correctly
kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment below but
let's just say give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following if i
had an audience between 20 and 30 years
old that were female and the product
were sandals okay what would some of
your subject lines be so i'm going to
give you a minute to think about that
and put it in the comment section below
now remember this is an interview based
question so you're gonna have to think
on the spot i'm gonna give you a minute
but if somebody presented that to you in
an interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so i
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action buy here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping i mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off i mean these
are key things you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention we can see it
for women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there
so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what is a b testing and give
some examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b testing
with subject lines so simply a b testing
when it comes to email marketing it's
just a method to analyze which of the
two email campaign strategies is most
effective all right you know you're
gonna do it based on open rate you can
do it by saying click rate you can do it
based on response rate and remember
you're putting one version of the email
against another version whether that be
the subject line whether it be the
content call to action whatever so
that's ideally what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what works
for your audience that's the end goal
for email for a b testing and email
marketing what's going to work and i
would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you can
try out images call to actions exclusive
offers what particular offer is gonna
work okay so if you're testing offers
then obviously that's gonna be response
rate if you're testing ctas and that's
going to be click-through rate if you're
testing subject lines that's going to be
open rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so
how to prevent email from getting into
spam so if you're an email marketer this
is your worst nightmare you don't want
your emails to get spammed so that
doesn't bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like mailchimp or
constant contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you're if
you know who you're talking to and you
have a cool subject line that's going to
get somebody to react and open and
that's going to prevent somebody from
spamming your email okay you can always
customize your from to make it look like
it's coming from in this case rob
sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why you sent it to me i
don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject
line's the most probably the most
important element in email marketing so
we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals targeting 20 to 30 year
old women you know to me i like the
subject line with the 50 off so that was
a number in the subject line so people
can actually see hey wow i get a whole
that works better than just a discount
okay remember one of those subject lines
had an emoji so don't be afraid to
include emojis in there for example when
i send out emails using you know during
the spring you might want to use flowers
perhaps to signify hey it's spring
winter's over so personalize the subject
lines remember that goes with segmenting
so if you know who your audience is your
your subject lines can be a little bit
more partial okay so opt for title case
subject lines okay so instead of making
a grammatical for example okay you want
to keep your subject lines short and to
the point remember you want to say
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention if you make it long
and drawn out and boring then people
aren't going to open it develop a sense
of urgency like hey we got 50 off
through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just set yourself up for better
performance
i'm greg jarbo
and what is that i mean what we're going
to talk about in this first module
of a
content marketing foundation course
is liberally content marketing um
okay what is it so content marketing is
not a new concept it's been around for
over 100 years in fact one of the
classic foundation stories of you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the michelin brothers in
france
and the michelin brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires
and they were trying to sell them along
with an innovative product at its time
called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of paris and
into the provinces because my god what
was worth going out there for
you know
were paris that's all happening here
and what the michelin brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book
was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants
not just restaurants nearby in paris but
restaurants out there
in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant i know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the ratatouille ah you
you gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way
since we're going to give you a guide
and you have to get out of paris in
order to get there we're going to tell
you where you can find gasoline along
the way
which hotels you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or
tire repair i mean that was in there but
it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which in
paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
we got the audience
to get into their new innovative
automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more flats
people had to replace their tires
but it was worth it
and oh by the way
michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing and we need to
come up with a concept
think back to the michelin guide it's
it's great foundation
so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions i'm not going to
read it to you
but i am going to highlight a couple of
words in the definition that i think are
absolutely
critical to any definition
of content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be relevant
and it also has to be
valuable
now if it's not relevant
then you're not actually meeting my
needs or interests
you know and why would i be interested
and we've gotten way too tired
of screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in florida i don't
use snow tires what the what the heck is
this commercial doing
you know interrupting what i'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out and the
valuable valuable can can work in a lot
of different ways it can be interesting
it can be useful
you know value
is an interesting proposition all by
itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you
that's a whole different kind of
proposition
i know there's some skeptics who are
saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name
for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're gonna deal with that
in module three
but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website
and that's not the social media it can
also create content that
your pr people can share with
reporters or bloggers
and that's not normally considered
social media content
and by the way
all of that content can be optimized so
maybe it actually is part of seo not
social media marketing in fact that's
the other place that content marketing
really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around february
when google rolled out the first of its
multiple versions of the panda update
all of a sudden even seos
started to pay attention to content
marketing why
because google changed the rules and
what google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search algorithm
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters i mean i've got
to actually tell stories that are
interesting i've got to
create information that's valuable
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
god bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing has grown it's
like tripled
in terms of web search interest since
the panda update
and we're talking about panda one of
course there was panda two panda three
panda four i mean come on
google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that uh
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you understand i do b2b
content marketing or i'm a small
business or part b i'm an enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly
maybe
on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know
content marketing has been around now
long enough and enough people have done
it that some research has been conducted
and it's been conducted against b2c
marketers and b2b marketers and small
business marketers and enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well
first of all
the most important thing
to be an effective b2c
content marketer
is you need a documented content
strategy
okay all right i mean people who are
winging it aren't as
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay
no great insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they've got to have somebody in
charge who oversees content marketing
oh lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what
it really helps if somebody is driving
this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics
than their less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are
actually more effective
are doing more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using
more than the ineffective ones
and last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh
effective content marketers
generally have
greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing for me but you
don't understand
i'm not a b2c marketer
okay
so let's take a look at the b2b content
marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to be an effective
b2b content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy
it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms
and guess what you spend a higher
percentage of your overall marketing
budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content markers but you
understand b2b is different yeah there's
a couple of small differences but guess
what
overall the top five criteria
are similar
and when you get to small business
here's what you're gonna see
same five criteria
and you're in an enterprise i know the
world is different for enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out ah there's a pattern
and the pattern is is i don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are you
can be b2c b2b you can be small business
you can be large enterprise
at the end of the day there are five
things that you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective
we've already covered these and are
there differences between small
businesses and large enterprises between
b2b and b2c well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone gonna come in and
like whack us
and the answer is um
maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes
they may encounter someone i like to
call the man in the chair
and the man in the chair actually refers
back to a classic mcgraw-hill ad
campaign from i think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your salesperson okay
i don't know anything about you i don't
know about your company i don't know
about your company's product i don't
know about your company's
you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not
having a content
marketing
program
content marketing has been around for
over a hundred years
but in the online world
customers are behaving in lots of new
ways and they're consuming content on
various kinds and types of devices
that changes things content marketing is
now about creating content that
consumers
will engage with and act upon not just
read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decision making process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase
and with a solid content marketing
strategy your customers buying decisions
can actually happen faster you can
basically
shorten the decision making process
and you can reach and expand
to new prospects
so one of the things that we hope that
you're going to
learn after
basically taking this module
you should be able to do the following
first of all
you can define content marketing and
other related concepts
secondly you should be able to explain
why content
needs to be relevant and valuable
in order for it to be effective
third you need to describe the overlap
between content marketing seo
social media marketing
fourth you need to name five traits
of effective content marketers
and last but not least you need to
explain the benefits
of content marketing these are our
objectives and hopefully they're going
to be your learning outcomes
so content marketing is not a new
concept it's been around for over 100
years in fact one of the classic
foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the michelin brothers in france
and the michelin brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires
and they were trying to sell them along
with an innovative product at its time
called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place france where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of paris and
into the provinces because my god what
was worth going out there for
you know
were paris it's all happening here
and what the michelin brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book
was the michelin guide
and the michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed
restaurants
not just restaurants nearby in paris but
restaurants out there
in the provinces
and the michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant i know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to die for the ratatouille ah you
you got to have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way since we're going to
give you a guide
and you have to get out of paris in
order to get there we're going to tell
you where you can find gasoline along
the way uh which hotels you might want
to stay at overnight and oh by the way
just in case you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a michelin tire because it's a
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or
tire repair i mean that was in there but
it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to their audience about what
their audience was truly passionate
about which in
paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience
to get into their new innovative
automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more flats
people had to replace their tires
but it was worth it
and oh by the way
michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know
greetings everyone and welcome my name
is rob sanders from simply learn and
today we're going to talk about content
marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're gonna get right into some of
the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interest so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it signs that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature that's part of
that product that you offer then that's
the segment you're gonna be writing
about so you need to collect your data
on your audience ahead of time and then
you're going to segment that audience
okay so you're not going to write
content for everyone because the shoe
doesn't necessarily fit for everyone
okay the shoe has to fit for specific
foot and in this case we're talking
about an audience we need to be able to
segment our audience out and you could
certainly segment them out by age by
gender by education level by income by
interest i mean these are just some of
the examples again it could be new
returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
have purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be an
age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
google analytics just got to go in the
analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
br it's age is broken out by age range
and you're going to see gender so you're
going to see a breakdown of gender and
use that to your advantage so if you're
going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly
you know how many fans you have broken
out by men versus women and then you can
see again same thing as google analytics
you could see an age range breakout you
could use twitter analytics i mean
twitter has shares some really good
insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on linkedin you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to target are c-level meaning
ceos
or cfos or cmos you know chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high-range managers or even vps so use
your audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage okay so let's jump into number
two we want to create high quality
content now i know this sounds like a
given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's gonna result
in a lot of things that are gonna
benefit you you know one you're gonna
come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's going to help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether it's a video or blog post or or
infographic you know people are going to
become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword plan or
any really any keyword planning tool
you always want to create original
content okay so you don't want to
plagiarize or take somebody else's
content and then you want to support
that content with compelling headlines
so if you have a piece of content you
got to get somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought-provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points change so these are all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content you there's some
other things that you should be aware of
you know grammatical mistakes you know
you need to avoid those there's no
reason for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and
hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake
you've just lost a lot of credibility
you know don't be afraid to add a clear
call to action at the end of your
content if somebody's interested in
reading it they're probably going to be
interested in taking the next step
whatever that next step is okay so
creating content that fulfills viewers
requirements meaning if somebody's
searching for something and your content
shows up in the search results then
they're actively looking for you what
are you offering them is it fulfilling
their requirements you know don't be
afraid to use examples throughout your
content in fact work in or integrate
some case studies in there show clear
examples to stress your points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you don't withhold it have
them come back and read a secondary blog
post or secondary piece that supports
the original now we want to move from
high quality content to running a b test
maybe test so important why because with
a b split testing you can increase your
conversion rates okay so four elements
to test in your content marketing
strategy so if you have content say a
blog and you're testing that blog you
know test out the images test out the
forms do you have a long form or short
form you know test out the content
length you can have a variation that is
a lot shorter than the original does
that increase or decrease bounce rates
play around with call to actions your
call to actions do matter you know do
you want to use a softer call to action
a softer tone or do you want to use
something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the
closer to purchasing and through that
funnel so a b testing to me is something
that should be naturally done with
google optimize it's free so with images
you know you could test a lot of
different variations of images anything
from people
to
you know outlandish imagery to just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's going to stay a little
bit longer on the page so you know
create a variation it's going to play
with that length okay so use analytics
to your advantage to figure out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say
matters and it changes versus say you
know europe or the west okay so keep
that in mind when you're making changes
on color or tone or placement and things
of that nature so you want to conduct a
competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics you know
looking at your audience you're doing
all this work you might as well take the
next step and figure out what it is your
competitors are doing so you can opt for
competitive analysis by identifying your
competitor's top performing content for
specific topics okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search
sem rush or moz or something like that
that's going to allow you to get some
good insight on competitor information
so keep in mind there are seo platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these seo
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so now we've done all this
homework we know what we want to say we
know who we want to say it to we're
ready to do some testing but we need to
find a format because it's not always
about a web page per se meaning content
on a web page there's not always about a
blog post with content in that blog post
okay we need to decide the type of
content that's going to fit what we're
trying to say so again you can go the
traditional route with just posting a
blog post and there's nothing wrong with
that because with a blog post you can
incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
i say official route with an e-book or
case study something that a user is
going to be able to take away with maybe
download okay something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an ebook now if you're into
talking like i am then you could
certainly do a podcast and podcasts are
always popular depending on the topic so
you got to be aware of the topic now
videos are always always a good option
you got the likes of video and video and
youtube and some other you know video
platforms out there that allow you the
ability to get found very quickly
especially with the likes of youtube you
know people use youtube before they go
on to purchasing a product so think
about that so if you're trying to get
somebody if you're trying to sway an
audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal
you know customer to taking the next
step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points try
using an infographic to convey those
points visually now again with blog
posts it should have valuable content
that can be shared by your website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so
and it shouldn't be published frequently
so maybe if this is something you're
doing annually then ebook could be the
format with a case study what you should
have a customer story that succeeded in
and you solving that customer's problem
so the case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience
and then videos are highly engaging
they're also shareable on blog posts and
pretty much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for a certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your target audience are
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or
what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice content via
email okay just make sure you know your
target audience is there's lots of
things you can do in email again you can
complement lots of different formats
within email as i mentioned before with
a podcast or a blog post so keep all
that in mind email's a good way to
communicate with your audience okay the
last point we want to make here is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
buzzfeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably won't exist without led
zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who led zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to led zeppelin okay so
you could see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
to say the headline or led zeppelin per
se but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 percent more likely to look at a
native ad than at a banner and so that
native ad in this case we're talking
about music needs to be sitting or
accompanied alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that's said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
via emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so
my favorite part of it all you go into
analytics going to facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available
you know if you're in it for search okay
how much traffic getting from search
where are you ranking so there are a lot
of things you need to think about so
think about the content that you're
producing and think about how you want
to be able to measure that content so
let's go back over our checklist here
so what you could do is create an
editorial calendar in fact i would
highly suggest you create an editorial
calendar in order to keep track of all
the content you've done over a period of
time are you making your content worth
reading that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
wanna you know make sure you're reusing
or using or adding to the content that
you've created guest post on influential
blogger websites you wanna add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
facebook you know leverage the feedback
you get from facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means seo so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadatas title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even all tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up in search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search okay
so you want to create a detailed summary
and title and again that goes along with
the title tag and meta description and
then you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and comment on
your blog so don't be afraid like i'm
going to do right now in this video is
if i'm missing anything from this
checklist feel free to comment hey i've
written my fair share content but i
could be talking to an audience that is
just as qualified as i am and they may
have some tips so feel free to comment
underneath this video now don't be
afraid to ask just like i just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so one know your
audience again you can lean on google
analytics you know demographic data
whether it be age or gender you can do
the same with facebook and twitter and
linkedin you know every platform has
some data you could take away create
high quality content when i mean high
quality content brainstorm some topics
has it already been written to death
about or is this unique you know don't
write something your competitors are
writing okay don't copy what your
competitors have written organize your
content support it with good imagery all
of these are tips to creating high
quality content okay when you create
that content think about running to
maybe test you know run some variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like sem rush and moz all you gotta do
is plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about
where a particular competitor ranks for
keyword or how many backlinks and what
websites are linking to them so all
that's available in these seo platforms
okay so you want to choose a suitable
content format we listed a few from
ebooks to case studies to podcasts to
infographics to blog posts to videos
it's up to you what you think is best
for your audience just keep in mind you
need to be able to measure it and so
that's the important thing if it doesn't
work the first time out then you might
want to consider changing out the
content format choose a content
management system you know plenty out
there wordpress is a good one if you're
going to be a blogger okay blogging
allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails okay so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so
you know if you created a video you know
put that video in the form of an email
and send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it
line your kpi so if it's an e-book or
case study
don't measure just traffic measure how
many people are actually downloading
them
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while
and i can tell you because i've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days
it was mostly technical with a little
bit of content sprinkled in so for
arguments like let's say 80 20
80 of what an seo needed to learn how to
do
had to deal with you know you know your
meta tags your metadata you know uh cms
systems even blah blah blah blah
and oh by the way yeah you need some
content on the page
well here we are a long time past that
and if this you you you look through
this slide here for example
this is the latest guidance from google
on the kind of content they want
and if you look through the list here
most of the items on it aren't technical
and frankly most of it is content and if
you think about it
what this means is that the job
description for seo has changed
dramatically
particularly beginning with the panda
update but then including the
penguin update and then hummingbird and
pardon me
more and more and more
seos had better be interacting with the
people who are creating
quality content
engaging content credible content
um useful content
it's not enough just to put keywords in
the right places anymore on pretty thin
content that won't get you where you
want to go
so again
different uh paths maybe the same
direction
but the folks in content marketing and
the folks in seo frankly need each other
and they may or may not recognize it in
your organization but you know it's a
starting point this is a conversation
you you probably need to have
content marketing is complex
it often overlaps with other elements of
marketing
uh the the most typical overlaps are
with social media marketing and seo
and uh they're probably already are
in your organization those kind of
groups
the seos may be on
one floor and uh the social media
marketing people may be in a different
building you know whatever
but
the new success formula says we got to
get all those folks to the same table
now we may have to do it virtually we
may have to use
you know webinars in order to hold those
kind of meetings who knows
but the point is is that uh you know the
world is shifting and organizational
structures need to shift with it
and again you know that's not something
you can change tomorrow
but that is something that will evolve
over time and
for what it's worth
it turns out that let's just say uh the
people who are in seo
they may or may not admit it at first
but they absolutely need to work with
the people in content marketing
why
because basically after panda and
penguin the rules shifted
and it's less about your title tag
and it's most mostly focused now on the
quality of your content
and whether that content is link worthy
which means it's really compelling
content it's remarkable content that's
content that's gonna get people to link
to it because wow that's
you know and that's not necessarily part
of the skill set that was required to be
a successful
seo five years ago or 10 years ago
so again you got to get these folks to
the table they've got to work together
you know and um
and again that means the organizational
structure probably needs to shift
and the same is true with the social
media marketing folks
you know
they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were
you know get lots of likes you know get
lots of fans
get lots of views get lots of twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us
and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out
none of those measures actually measure
real success
because they're focused on being
successful on the platform
boy i have lots of fans as opposed to
being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales
so there is a real
real discrepancy between let's just say
the center of gravity
okay it's not facebook you're not going
to make
a lot of money on facebook
you know it's just not set up to do
business
you've got to get those folks that
you've engaged in facebook
to your website where they can buy
something
and that's a you know radical shift for
all the folks who are in social media
marketing to say wait wait time out
but that's not what i was told a couple
years ago and the answer is that's
correct what we've learned over time is
that being engaging is useful
if it's harnessed to
a benefit and i'll tell you in most
organizations the social media marketing
people are under cloud
because they aren't delivering business
benefit
and they too
need to learn to work with the content
marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of
content that actually generates leads
and sales as opposed to
you know is inexpensive to create to get
my next fan or my next twitter follower
so the key metrics here are no longer
how many likes or comments or shares did
you get that's nice
but
how many sales leads did you generate
what percentage of those converted into
sales
that's a radical change
but again it helps when the
social media marketing people are at the
table with the content marketing people
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn and today we're going
to talk about how to rank number one on
google high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily going to get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings and
we want to prevent that we want to move
up the rankings we want to be number one
on google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summer time and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do i make you
know a bread or how do i make a specific
type of bread or how do i make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and trends and whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question that's the whole
idea behind content content is not just
to fill a page it's to really fulfill
users requirements that's when you get
good engagement so if somebody's typing
in something on google and they're
looking for an answer your content
should answer that question but we also
want to make the content readable so in
other words you know write for your
audience don't impress anybody with very
high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey i've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hat techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to write an article
about how to write good engaging content
we don't necessarily have to write all
that out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
i like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you could
save them on really any social platform
so infographics tend to tell a better
story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person is engaged so
we're going to rank that favorable so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again those best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords in your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to
make the best banana bread or how to
make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include lsi keywords so what i mean
by lsi keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way the
image doesn't load then at least the alt
text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are steps to
creating high quality content and so
let's look at an example here and this
is a three month old post on buzzfeed
and it's 21 pictures that restore your
faith in humanity so it has a lot of
likes a lot of tweaks and that means
it's engaged people are engaged when
reading that and so if we go and look at
it as an example we could see it on a
buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content creating high quality videos and
some of the best practices around that
so along with everything we mentioned
about choosing the right keywords we
always need to keep in mind that the
videos we create need to be of high
quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords this is a
primary factor in ranking so in order to
have keywords we need to have content
and in order to rank we need to have you
know good content so let's talk a little
bit about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or relevant to the topic it
won't rank so that's just common sense
so you need to create content that's
aligned with the topic obviously and
then that way you have keywords that are
aligned with the content so but if you
have content really isn't aligned with
the topic then you're not going to rank
no matter how much you've optimized that
video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we've created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention is simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched it's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so yours are engagement
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so we talk about watch time so if one
video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with it on
how there's no videos are no different
than say a presentation if you've done a
powerpoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline then we
want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of youtube are
high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day view
users going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
titles online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
giving maximum relevant information can
help gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you want to create a video
yeah you can create another video about
what is machine learning but just make
sure it has your own take on it you're
the subject matter expert when creating
the video create it with your own
original content have high audio quality
and video effects so just like you see
here on this video we have effects in it
and the audio is of high quality meaning
no background noise no distortion and we
want to be able to speak clearly in the
video so you want to speak clearly
loudly concise just as i'm trying to do
now so that you can understand what i'm
trying to say or what the viewers trying
to to understand when they're watching
the video so watching and listening are
two of the components and you want to
make sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline i referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out all
together so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in youtube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example i can see you know
43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see 28.6
watch it for six minutes plus so that's
the audience retention it gives us an
idea in terms of percentage how many
people or percentage of people watch the
video at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content not pausing
you know going from one point to the
other those are all best practices to
keep the viewer engaged and then we want
to add resources from well-known sites
so throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well if i go
back again to my audience retention
report how engaging was it well i could
see 42 percent 43
watched on average of 3 minutes and 21
seconds so to me that's pretty good of
course we always want a hundred percent
of the video the video is seven minutes
long if almost half of our audience saw
over half of the video then i would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video if
your video is not engaging you know you
can always go back and edit it or fix it
or tweak it so remember the average view
duration for all videos and top
performing videos listed by all time we
can look at that information as well in
addition we can look at demographics so
we can get an overview of the age gender
and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within youtube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website sign ups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one
remarket your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertised to
them through this you can build
awareness and engagement with your
audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content
this is why you need to focus on
google's featured snippet this position
also known as position 0 enhances and
draws user attention on the search
engine's result page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves in a way they're selling
themselves by being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel
see how he himself is the brand and if
you've gone through his content you know
it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you are
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five back up your
arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content this will
also help your content have a greater
chance of being found indexed and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you back up your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are bus sumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them and earn their trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 of them felt content marketing
was really important to their digital
marketing campaigns and more than 25
percent of their budgets are used for
visual advertising content like images
infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such evergreen
article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content
instagram and pinterest for visual
content twitter for smaller snappy
content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after you're done
engaging with the good content that you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write but are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know information from a
legitimate source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social in in
the form of case study and create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
calendars to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people to come back for more they
know when you're going to post they're
going to be waiting for it and if it's
every tuesday morning 8 o'clock hey post
it tuesday morning 8 o'clock your users
will get used to that schedule and it
does help build up your following it
does help help build up your community
and in the end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship and then having a content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up whether it be a blog post a
an infographic a video about different
topics okay some other advantages here
saving time it just allows you to
prepare for the future when you can
prepare you're efficient and when you're
efficient you're not wasting time and so
to me having a content calendar is a
must because a lot of us are busy who
has time especially if you're going to
work in a new company let's say writing
content you definitely want to have a
content counter because you're going to
want to use that time to efficiently
plan this is a new company you're going
to start working at you want to
understand who this company is what
they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh and
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
twitter if you're putting a content
calendar and
together for twitter well you don't want
to have the same tweets every other day
so it does ensure that you're getting
tweets out there that are fresh that are
new that are different and again figure
out what works a content counter makes
it easier to measure results and
optimize performance so you always want
to you know maybe put some metrics in
with your content calendar so you can
see side by side content historically
that is performed content that is not
performed okay so next question you may
get what type of content works in each
stage of the customer life cycle so you
have awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website
you can have an ebook where people can
actually download and read it or you can
have a blog where people can comment or
landing page where they can fill out a
form submission you have evaluation so
with social media we know there's a lot
of engagement going on but when you're
putting content out there you can
certainly open it up to testimonials
okay you can generate white papers okay
or you can generate case studies case
studies a good way for companies to
evaluate what you've done in the past if
you've worked in it for a specific
product in the past and it's worked you
certainly want to put that out there for
potential clients in that same industry
purchase trying to get people to
purchase what are you going to do well
you can certainly have landing pages a
nice you know website a nice shopping
cart with some nice content okay
onboarding emails get those emails out
there and get people to go back to the
website and purchase of course you can
have product and service details as well
meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay you post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog roundups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased and you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
going to be your advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not gonna share that so
you're gonna have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always helps
you to see what you put in that content
calendar but there are some other
methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
cora i always look at korra core is
interesting entertaining informational
people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience ie street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin is more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you haven't an email list send it out
and let people know this content's there
put a link in the email or or even a
piece or snippet or preview of the
content in the email so you're using the
email to broadcast and encourage people
to you know if it's an ebook get the
rest of the ebook okay you could
certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey i got
i got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
google or facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again you've
done all the work you've put the content
calendar together you've got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it social email guest blogging
but you want to determine how it's doing
well depends on the channel really is
what it comes down to so if it's organic
search you want to be able to see if
it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments etc of course
you can always look at analytics and see
how much traffic that blog post is
getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audits audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course
you want to publish and manage your
content after it's all said and done so
these are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so if they fit a certain age range
your generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay that
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is i'm greg jarbo i'm a
member of the market motive faculty
in this first section we're going to
talk about what content marketing is how
it works
and also explore why it works
it seems like a new buzzword to you it's
actually a term that's been around for
quite some time
it's just web search interest in content
marketing has tripled since 2010
according to google trends and that's
why a lot of people are now just
starting to get their arms around it
so what is content marketing
well according to rebecca lee a friend
of mine who wrote an article in
advertising age
content marketing is not just a
glorified way to say social media
marketing it's actually a little broader
concept so content marketing does
include social media and you can use
blogs facebook twitter
youtube vimeo linkedin google plus
pinterest
foursquare instagram flickr stumbleupon
tumblr slideshare and quora and you can
put all of those together
in a content marketing program
and all of this content
can be optimized so it can be found in
search engines
as well as in social media
or in the usual places like your website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic venn diagram
brian clark of copy blogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content marketing in which she's created
this particular diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three
is where he positions content marketing
and that may help you understand where
it fits it's sort of a little bit of
this a little bit of that but it also
shows you both the potential leverage
that you can get when you begin
combining these elements
but also the potential conflicts you may
encounter inside an organization who
says hey wait a second that's my job and
the real challenge to content marketing
is getting people who have been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction
to actually collaborate and coordinate
what they're doing
and leveraging each other's capabilities
to create something that's a little more
powerful
so with that we have reached the end of
day 4 of our digital marketing week on
day 5 that is tomorrow we are going to
learn about the various digital
marketing tools thank you all for
watching today's live session i hope it
was useful and interesting see you
tomorrow thanks again and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you